poczobut forme des futurs une autre
rapport accablant amnistie
internationale demande à l'industrie des
produits électronique et automobile de
vérifier d'où vient le cobalt qu'elle
utilise ce minerai est trop souvent
extraits dans des conditions dangereuses
même par des enfants notamment dans la
république démocratique du congo avec
ces minerais qui est essentiel pour
alimenter des outils qu'on utilise tous
les jours
oui en fait même sans savoir un solide
en fait le cobalt est utilisé pour la
production entre autres de batteries à
base de lithium ion elle rend les
retrouve en fait dans par exemple les
téléphones portables dans les batteries
de voitures dans d'autres batteries
qu'on va utiliser pour tous les
équipements électroniques ce qui est
intéressant c'est que 50% de la
production mondiale en fait provient
d'un seul et même pays
c'est à dire la république démocratique
du congo il ya quelques années le
gouvernement a vidé la population on n'a
pas d'argent à mettre dans les mines
mais c'est un secteur porteur donc aller
gratter vous-même prenez un marteau et
un burin et ce qui est arrivé c'est
qu'on a énormément de mines artisanales
avec des conditions de travail
absolument épouvantable et il y aurait à
peu près 40 mille enfants qui
travaillent dans ce type de mina pour
aller chercher le cobalt et tout ça en
fait pour des salaires de misère en
parle de 1 à 2 dollars par jour avec
d'énormes dangers à la clé parce que si
aucune formation il n'ya pas
d'encadrement
donc on a des enfants qui sont par
exemple exposé à des poussières
hautement toxiques qui n'ont pas de
masque et bien souvent aussi comme ils
vont creuser avec des équipements de
fortune des tunnels
ces tunnels ne sont pas sécuritaires et
un moment donné ça s'écroule et ça
devient en quelque sorte lurton peut
malheureusement c'est vrai mais que
demande d'amnistié internationale alors
alors amnesty international a contacté
en fait 16 multinationales vraiment on
les connaît à peu près toute la banque
ce soit à port que ce soit samsung sony
ou microsoft pour savoir un petit peu
moins est-ce que vous êtes conscient de
la provenance du cobalt la plupart ont
vraiment balayé cette question du revers
de la main et on discute et on a
peut-être enquêter mais pour l'instant
ça ne nous concerne pas trop donc aussi
amnesty international demande au
gouvernement et aux états concernés de
faire plus attention d'être plus
responsable qu'il ait des lois qu'ils
soient plus fortes pour prévenir et à
garantir une certaine sécurité pour
l'extraction du minerai
mais jusqu'ici c'est vraiment resté
lettre morte donc un minerai qui
exploite et dangereusement sur un
continent qui aude aboutissent des
jeunes aux déchets électroniques
oui en fait c'est un pull ironie de
l'histoire parce que dans le fond c'est
un minerai qui est utilisé pour
fabriquer des équipements électroniques
qu'on va utiliser pendant quelques
années on va s'en lasser on va à nouveau
gadget alors qu'est ce qu'on fait en
envoie au recyclage et parmi ce
recyclage de déchets électroniques bien
tout un trafic international et donc ces
équipements vont se retrouver un moment
donné du côté de l'afrique de l'inde où
bon dans certains jeux ou la chine
mènent donc il ya 50 millions de tonnes
de déchets électriques parents qui se
retrouvent dans ces pays là et encore
une fois mais ce sont des pays qui font
face à des problèmes respiratoires et le
système nerveux problèmes de cancer
parce que ça devient des dépotoirs où
les enfants les gens vont jouer dans ces
matières toxiques et évidemment la
contamination des eaux est aussi une des
résultants de ce problème donc on voit
ces espèces de cercle vicieux et ça va
pas s'améliorer parce que la
consommation de ce genre de produits
électroniques va continuer de façon
exponentielle pour les prochaines années
avec tous les problèmes que l'on connaît
trouvons les téléphones équitable
essayons merci frédéric